Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij e oggi
per la mia e per la vostra gioia ma
soprattutto per la mia senza tanti suoi
geometrici questo mi ha fatto Cristiano
Ronaldo non ce la stavo più facendo Raga
ve lo dico questo Ecco questo è già sta
già piangendo di suo Non voglio piangere
Meglio meglio così ma va bene cos'è sta
roba che cazzo è cos'è il portale per
Narnia tatto vuoi il touch Ring tutto Ah
ok Ah devo saltare tipo
devo premere anche quando salto
praticamente bellissimo Okay allora
ragazzi
niente Volevo dire primo tentativo e lo
finisco Ma mmm Mi sa proprio di non lo
so che ce la posso fare Me lo sento
dentro stavolta quella buona
sorprendo il mondo praticamente vai così
vai così lo vinco subito convinto
proprio gasatissimo vai
Oh mio Dio mio Dio non mi devo muovere
perché sono perdo subito a caso Ok ok
un fenomeno ragazzi è un cane ve lo sto
dicendo un casino Eh ve lo dico già che
è chi è che ha cagato cubi e li ha messi
in mezzo
Madonna mi sto salvato Ok devo stare
calma perché so già che mi sto agitando
e quindi perdo Ok ok ragazzi
non si Madonna Ok
mi sono salvato in una maniera
incredibile direi ragà
Mmm Madonna Non ci credo non ci sto
credendo non si possono se parlo perdono
so già devo stare zitto devo stare zitto
ma non ce la faccio ragazzi non ce la
faccio Madonna
Matteo dice credo fermi un attimo
mi sta salendo l'adrenalina in una
maniera incredibile mi sta salendo
l'adrenalina Sì sì
[Musica]
ragazzi è stato eh come cazzo è
possibile che ci ho messo 101 tentativi
per fare sta merda
e uno due per farne per fare questo è
impossibile è stato assurdo dry House
Prova a fare ancora questo Sei
bellissimo Gianfrancesco te lo dico però
partiamo male mi fai già incazzare è
assurdo ma va bene con ogni tanto mi
succede quando me lo sento mi succede
che riesco non so perché non sentivo già
dall'inizio anche in questo non sto
sentendo vai così in realtà ragazzi ogni
tanto mi succede sta cosa che non lo so
mi sento che vinco e vinco a qualcosa mi
succede spesso sta roba manco per il
cazzo mi succede mai però vabbè non
importa Raga voi fate finta che sia vero
perché potrebbe essere non lo so cioè mi
è andata di culo Oh mio Dio oh mio Dio
no no no no no devo saltare [ __ ]
Che fai ragazzi Ah già minchia Io mi
sono dimenticato di tenere devo tenere
in alto il mouse che sono sembra che non
gioco io io non l'ho fatto Ragazzi ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] non l'ho fatto
finora Ragazzi ma vado nella vostra
fiducia ho giocato io anche il terzo No
no abbiamo giocato io davvero non sono
sarebbe stato tragico Ma poi Ragazzi ma
io mi sono sempre chiesto Ma chi è che
fa ste musiche che sono bellissime
[ __ ] non me lo devo neanche
chiedere mi hanno scritto in molti tipo
farvi fai geometry Dash che questa è la
copia di geometry Dash quando sotto il
video di The Impossible Game cazzata
ragazzi è impossibile che mi è stato il
primo a uscire così Quindi non dite 'ste
blasfemie che non è vero okay okay okay
okay perfetto supposta che cazzo cosa ma
serio
è una presa per il culo cosa Dov'è la
mia adorata supposta bruttissima sta
frase perché mi si è girato Ma perché
hai bevuto zio si vede dalla faccia
proprio come se non fosse difficile cioè
già prima maledizione Cioè se fossi
sullo smartphone girerei il telefono
però Minchia mi sa che gira nel monitor
non mi conviene ok ok ok
È impossibile
A meno che non mi metto a testa in giù
quando premi un attimo mo che ci arrivo
mi metto a Testaccio ci provo sarà
tragico ci provo lo stesso però
Ma [ __ ] tanto ragazzi lo sapevo
che finiva così Quindi non fate i
commenti
non mi Guardate mai piano forse ce la
posso fare stavolta ce la faccio son
carico son carico ok Vai forza
Sì ok È impossibile perché non capisco
quando devo saltare quando lo devo stare
fermo è impossibile giuro
Madonna
non c'è mai nella vita proprio perché
come casa sta musica Oh mio Dio
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
proprio no proprio no no non so se ho
già detto no però no pochi cazzi perché
questo è impossibile non esiste
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta ragazzi ce l'ho fatta Sì
dimmi che non si capovolge il nodo
adesso lo devo vincere per forza Non ce
la farò mai più se perdo Adesso basta
non è possibile ragazzi devo vincere
però purtroppo no no no basta No no
sposta di merda lassù poi io pensavo si
capovolgesse di nuovo e invece c'era la
risposta di merda Credetemi sto gioco mi
demolisce le capacità cerebrali e già
sono poche però eh No veramente raga È
assurdo Non so perché mi avete
consigliato aggiornamento tra tutti i
giochi di merda che potevate di merda
sottolino di merda che potevate
consigliarvi perché è geometri Dash
Proprio negli merda nel senso che mi fa
incazzare non che è brutto forse anche
brutto però dipende tutto da questo
livello come lo finisco Minchia sembra
che sto combattendo in Arena Ragazzi ma
[ __ ] [ __ ] e [ __ ]
perché scherzi ma i creatori di sto
gioco quando l'hanno fatto l'hanno detto
ma che bello Kevin perché non ne
facciamo uno simile No seriamente non
voglio sapere problemi che affliggono
queste persone voglio conoscerle e
stringerli la mano ma forte e la mano lo
voglio vederli piangere mentre li a
stringo
Sì sì
oh mio Dio ragazzi calmi che mi sto
cagando di nuovo quando succede così il
mio cuore va a 1000 e perdo per quello
convinto proprio la supposta ragazzi
mi chiamo non sbaglio più su Sì mi
chiami più grossi ha mangiato hamburger
stavolta ok ok sì sì Oh mio Dio oh mio
Dio dimmi che finisce così ti prego ti
prego ti supplico No il cazzo
[Musica]
Oddio Oddio
sto male giusto male Sto malissimo Sto
malissimo Ditemi che c'è un rilevatore
di battito cardiaco Perché non potete
capire quanto sto morendo in questo
momento tantissimi cieli e tutto quanto
quanto sei bello giusto Io voglio la
curiosità solo per vedere No io
veramente a parte gli scherzi solo
ma non mi interessa neanche Guarda
Grazie di avermelo fatto Grazie uno per
cento sono soddisfatto Vabbè ragazzi
concluso qui l'episodio perché mi piace
tanto giocare a questi giochi però
da fare la settimana enigmistica
d'accordo ragazzi Direi che posso
concludere qui il video di la verità
quando ho fatto questo video Stavo
giocando ancora la demo di geometry Dash
adesso è uscito il gioco completo quindi
ragazzi dal prossimo episodio vedo di
fare anche più di due livelli a episodio
Se volete che io lo faccio alla prossima
episodio perché ma in realtà non lo
volete che io faccia al prossimo
episodio non lo sapete ancora ma voi non
lo volete quindi ragazzi se il video Vi
è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di Facebook qua nei miei
video trovate nella descrizione Se
volete iscrivetevi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi